[Musica]
buonasera e grazie di essere ancora
tutti qua si dice che le nostre
democrazie sono in crisi
si dice anche che la democrazia se
stessa non funziona più allora stasera
con voi vorrei vedere come fare per
riuscire a far funzionare le nostre
democrazie
oggi forse anche da umani per cominciare
vorrei parlarvi di democrazia epistemica
la democrazia epistemica è una corrente
di teoria politica nata 40 anni fa negli
stati uniti il suo obiettivo è di
dimostrare scientificamente che la
democrazia ci permette di prendere delle
decisioni buone delle decisioni che ci
permettono di migliorarci nella
conoscenza politica in greco conoscenza
si dice episteme ecco perché questa
corrente si chiama democrazia epistemica
diciamo che la democrazia ed isterica e
basata su un teorema matematico che si
chiama il teorema di condor se con docs
è un filosofo francese della rivoluzione
rivoluzione francese quindi fine
settecento è rimasto molto conosciuto
per i suoi lavori matematici anche i
filosofici teorema dice questo
prendiamo un tot di persone per esempio
noi stasera abbiamo una decisione da
fare e abbiamo due opzioni una sbagliata
una conforma alla verità
il teorema dice semplicemente che se
ognuno di noi sa ha una probabilità
superiore al 50 per cento di non
sbagliare quindi di prendere la buona
opzione allora saremo sicuri che la
buona decisione sarà presa alla
maggioranza quindi semplicemente questo
teorema dice se il popolo abbastanza
educato allora la democrazia non sbaglia
ecco perché
questa corrente democrazia epistemica è
molto famosa è molto sviluppata nella
ricerca odierna anglosassone soprattutto
devo dire che in italia non è ancora
bene conosciuta né in francia da dove
vengo io come potete sentire purtroppo
dal mio accento è però
[Applauso]
però vorrei fare una domanda quello che
ha appena detto avete veramente creduto
perché è sbagliatissimo ma veramente
sbagliato inizio no diciamo che per
essere onesto il teorema in se stesso
il teorema matematico è vero e giusto e
un tè roma in un teorema semplice di
convergenza che sarà è conosciuto un po
più tardi nel 800 come teorema di gauss
la plus per la sua applicazione alla
teoria politica non ha senso
prendiamo un esempio semplice la
decisione da fare tutti insieme dove
mangiamo stasera questo è semplice due
possibilità fuori o a casa potrebbe
pensare che fuori è vero perché possiamo
far funzionare l'economia così o potete
pensare che a casa sarebbe un po più
vero perché prepariamo quello che
mangiamo quindi è più carino alla fine
non ha senso ovviamente una questione di
verità è una questione di preferenza una
questione di scelta e questa nozione di
ben di scelta e di esprimere la sua
preferenza è veramente fondamentale
nella teoria politica
quindi pensiamo che il fatto di aver
voluto ma tematizzare la teoria politica
ci ha allontanati dal dalla cosa
semplicemente che volevamo modellizzare
all'inizio e quindi ci siamo dimenticati
un po l'essere umano e quando vedete
sentite i dibattiti politici sentite
tante cifre tante statistiche però alla
fine quello che se che se dimentica
sempre alla fine dell'essere umano il
cittadino che comunque dovrebbe essere
al centro della politica
quindi il grande filosofo e il mondo
fosse ci spiega nella crisis che questo
proprio il problema della scienza
odierna che se troppo allontanata
dell'essere umano per andare verso una
scienza obiettivi st diciamo una scienza
che vuole quantificare tutto però ci
siamo persi allora torniamo forse
alla base la base in teoria politica è
semplicemente questa domanda cos'è
un'entità politica allora possiamo dire
è un posto dove vi è più gente possiamo
anche dire è un posto dove la gente
scambia cose ok vero però non basta non
basta dice aristotele perché abbiamo
dimenticato ogni ingrediente
fondamentale per la politica
ecco quello che ci dice aristotele la
polis quindi la città e la comunità del
buon vivere
mettete già una cosa che la città l'ente
politico non è fatto per l'economia
qualsiasi cosa è fatto soltanto card il
buon vivere anche questo lo
dimentichiamo spesso questo non si
potrebbe realizzare senza i matrimoni
misti e i divertimenti della vita in
comune tutto ciò è opera dell'amicizia
perché la scelta del vivere insieme e
l'amicizia quindi senza amicizia non se
non c'è né stato né città e questo lo
dimentichiamo purtroppo troppo spesso
però ovviamente gli parlo adesso di
un'amicizia nel senso filosofico del
termine cioè la filosofia lo sapete
probabilmente è il fatto di avere un
interesse verso il mondo una curiosità e
verso le cose che non conosciamo ancora
e lavoria di conoscerli
allo stesso modo l'amicizia di cui vi
sto parlando
e il fatto di voler e conoscere la gente
che non conosciamo la volontà di
conoscere queste cose e scoprirli e
anche forse capirli
allora il problema che oggi ci siamo un
po persi abbiamo forse dimenticato il
senso della democrazia nel senso che
pensiamo troppo spesso che la democrazia
consiste in questo vado ogni tanto a
votare e basta questo è falso
tra due direzioni c'è un sacco
di spazio per un po di amicizia quindi
abbiamo svuotato il senso della
democrazia e oggi lo possiamo riempie
nar e quindi vi vorrei dare qualche
esempio storico su questa amicizia
nell'ambito politico primo esempio
dall'antichità dopo la sconfitta di
atene contro sparto atene fu governata
dai trenta tiranni per quasi un anno
dopo questo quando la democrazia tornata
ad atene un accordo è scritto i
cittadini e c'è un punto interessante in
questo accordo nessuno avrà il diritto
di rimproverare il passato
e sì perché per vivere insieme abbiamo
bisogno soltanto di guardare quello che
possiamo costruire quello che possiamo
creare tutti insieme nel futuro
quando dico tutti insieme è veramente
tutti insieme nel senso che aristotele
ancora lui scrive una cosa semplice
semplicissima che dimentichiamo troppo
spesso se una persona in una società
viene esclusa
allora per forza per forza questa
persona sarà un nemico interno
quindi il più grande rischio per noi per
le nostre società e di escludere gente
invece include reintegrare è sempre una
cosa buona per le nostre società questo
è importante poi come fare con la gente
diverse da noi
michel de montaigne è uno scrittore
francese che ha vissuto nel xvi secolo e
le guerre di religioni e comunque lui
dice questo non condivido questo errore
comune di giudicare gli altri
rispetto a quello che sono io concepisco
semplicemente che ci sono delle qualità
diverse dalle mie
ammetto più facilmente la differenza
dalla somiglianza
sì perché l'amicizia vuol anche dire
l'umiltà nel senso che una persona
diversa da me mi può dare qualcosa che
non l'ho già mi posso arricchire con
questa persona è anche quello che dice
antoine de saint exupery l'autore del
famosissimo piccolo principe che dice
semplicemente seggi fresco date al
contrario di vederti di aumento però
possiamo chiedere abbiamo chiaramente
bisogno di aumentarsi dalle persone che
non conosciamo che sono diverse da noi
si la risposta è sì e viene da leopold
sedar senghor primo presidente del
senegal e grande poeta soltanto una
parentesi che sun gol è stato presidente
cristiano di eder senegal composto al 90
per cento di musulmani questo non è mai
stato un problema per nessuno
e importante a ricordarlo
[Applauso]
sangue scrive questo come vivere
altrimenti che nell'altro sul filo
dell'altro perché alla fine vivere per
noi e vivere con gli altri e quello che
ci rende umani perché come lo dice
aristotele ancora l'ultima volta lo
giuro l'uomo è anche la donna ovviamente
è un animale sociale cioè un animale
politico perché in greco si dice
politico zone quindi come appunto vivere
la politica con questa questo concetto
di amicizia ti parlerò di tre città
atene roma e anche siena la siena della
fine del medioevo la siena del governo
dei 99 ad atene e anche a siena c'era
questa idea di anziché e leggere le
persone tirare la sorte perché con
questo modo ognuno aveva l'obbligo di
interessarsi minimamente agli altri ai
problemi degli altri per avere la
capacità di decidere qualcosa di giusto
per loro poi a roma e anche a siena
c'era questa idea che quando una persona
veder veniva eletta alla fine del
proprio mandato non poteva essere
rieletta per un tot di anni così due
cose prima cosa questa persona doveva
reintegrare la società normale la vita
normale e poi così non c'era una classe
politica troppo stretta che il popolo
vedeva come il nemico
allora oggi
vedete che la democrazia non è affatto
un teorema matematico è uno sforzo
permanente di democrazia e uno sforzo
permanente di amicizia e un po e uno
sforzo di legame tra di noi quello che
desse i legami in greco si chiama andrà
psoto noi oggi è anche domani dobbiamo
essere i rhapsody del
la nostra democrazia perché se no
altrimenti non ci sarà più senso a
questa democrazia sarà la sconfitta
quindi per ricordare una frase molto
semplice possiamo dire soltanto questo
per concludere
quando penso a me penso a te quando
penso a te penso a me grazie mille
[Applauso]